Hi Gita lycan Vespa, yes, standard, yes,
Indonesia is made by Angek, accept it
like we ride a Vespa on the road. It
has its own pride for
us fish children.
It's been Oggy from the past
until now, when he was extreme
in high school, he played because he was too used to riding
a standard Vespa, so he wanted to
create something even more extreme,
even weirder, huh?
first, connecting the evidence, the
Vespa wants to make side wheels, how many
Unisba can we have 1011 wheels or
not, the welding machine continues to make it, he was
self-taught at Extreme Bass Brothers
or small groups people who generally
found footage of three telephones Year one
piece of Indonesia and the world Stories
with friends and
gave Yes my motorbike that was
passing by me later  it's something else like that
actually the show is ok I want to sleep on your
motorbike you can't you can't You're too much
let's raise us together
here Ride the fake motorbike Velvet Norwich
City Ajeng we all feel
Indonesia is beautiful
yo yo it's like when we're on the road we
meet each other  the coast or the mountains of Jang, which we
didn't know about before
, we feel weirder and more beautiful,
right
hai hu hu